-So happy to have our friend
Fred Armisen back
and leading the band.
How are you, Fred?
-I'm doing great.
-I'm always so happy to see you,
and I'm always so impressed
because not only this show,
but you have so many other
products --
projects and products.
That's something I think
speaks to your range.
-Yes.
-But you also are a bit...
you're a bit of a fashionista.
And I was really excited
to hear this,
that you're developing
a new summer shoe.
-That's right.
-[ Chuckles ]
-So...
So I'm developing this shoe.
-Yeah.
-And it's basically...
it's a sort of backpack, right?
So, like, you know
how you have to, like,
switch out your shoes
all the time?
-No, wait, when?
-So, like...
In life, you know,
you're always like,
"Oh, I got to put on my sneakers
or boots or whatever."
-Okay.
-So I've got this backpack
that's like a metal locker
and it's got all your,
like, favorite
different types of shoes.
And so you've got it with you.
But it's with --
It's like not in -- in sight.
It's not in vision.
So behind your head, one, like
one locker piece is like that.
And then in your shoulders
it's like three shoes
and then just going down.
So it follows your...
-So no one knows
you're carrying
all your shoes with you.
-Nobody knows.
-Wow. So that's nice.
-You can just talk to someone.
And so then you've got a code
so that there are no thieves,
and, you know...
-But a thief couldn't see it
because it's invis-- so what...
What is the fear
of how a thief would...?
-Because thieves are always
sort of like behind you.
-Oh, I see. Yeah.
-And so...
So then you've got
a little combination
and you can put on
whatever shoes you want.
-Great.
-And, yeah, and that's it.
They're free...
[ Laughter ]
...for...
every New Yorker,
every Californian,
everyone from Washington State.
They're free.
-How do you --
How do you you make money, Fred?
-It doesn't -- That's --
It doesn't matter.
-Yeah.
-Do you know what I mean?
-What's it called?
Do you have a name for it?
-None. No name.
[ Laughter ]
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-[ Indistinct ]